[Music]
thanks for stopping by the pretty
intense podcast on the show is Anita
morjani Anita had a near-death
experience she had cancer for four years
and was given days to live and she had a
near-death experience that shifted her
entire reality and she essentially
dissolved her cancer within weeks so
she's an author as well she's written
six books her newest book is called
sensitive is the new strong but her
original based on her near-death
experience was called dying to be me
which was a big time bestseller look the
story is out there about exactly what
happened with this near-death experience
and so there's alluding to it within
what we talked about but more than
anything it's really about the lessons
learned it's about what she learned on
the other side how to live in this
reality what are the energies that are
operating this reality and controlling
the experience that we're having and how
do we get to them like how can we live
in a different reality for ourselves
which then if we all do that it's a
different reality in general so for
anyone out there struggling on any level
especially if there's any illness with
you or anyone around you this is a must
listen to given the fact that this world
puts a lot of fear into us and we talk
about the danger of dangers of fear
orienting yourself in an entirely new
way and focusing on the things that
bring you Joy and having self-love and
understanding how things work here
um might just pay off for you in the
long run and you might you might not
have to deal with the most difficult
things in life please enjoy the show
please hit subscribe and the bell for
notifications and let me know in the
comments let me know if you've had any
experiences let me know what your
thoughts are and if this is played into
your life at all what kind of things do
you do at the events so I speak a lot I
share about my near-death experience and
I share the lessons that I learned from
having been on the other side and how
it's affected this life so I do a lot of
speaking events events and my husband
travels with me I have a little
Entourage my assistant Abby she also
travels with me so it's it's great I
actually love going on the road yeah do
you love being on stage too yeah it's so
of course I was nervous in the beginning
but
um but now I'm so used to it I actually
I enjoy the audience interaction I just
I love I'd much rather have a real life
audience of physical people to talk to
than to speak on camera now Zoom is fine
where I'm talking to you right now it's
great
um but my least favorite thing to do is
when people say just record yourself for
40 minutes of speaking so I'm just
speaking to camera and there's no one on
the other side I dislike that so much I
do too it feels so impersonal I feel
kind of silly I guess I don't know
because you're having to because there's
an energy to the connection and the
emotion with people which we're going to
have a whole deep dive on energy
obviously but like when there's people
there or even just one person asking
questions you're like orienting with
some
energies either direction there's a
feeling there's a connection there's but
when you're having to do that by
yourself too camera and pretend like
someone's there I just am not good at
faking things so like it's hard for me
to basically if I have to do anything
like that like record a little quick
video for like Instagram or a video or
something I I just tell myself to be as
over acting and ridiculous as possible
off the top and then it'll be good
that's actually good advice I'm gonna
remember that for when I have to do it
just overreacting the camera overacting
somebody once gave me the advice that
when you're having photos taken over
smile like do the cheesiest grin but on
a photo it looks like a million dollar
smile I'm sure there's been so many
Lessons Learned along the way but of
course like the biggest one coming from
your experience having cancer for four
years and you know being given days to
live and then going through this
near-death experience where you went to
the other side and then being able to
essentially eliminate and dissolve the
cancer within weeks correct yep yep
what I wanna I'm really curious about
the energy like the energy of fearing
something and fearing death and fearing
disease that you had when you got up
into that point and went up to the point
where you had the near-death experience
what is that what what is happening on a
Quantum level or an energetic level when
you're so afraid of something and
essentially focusing so hard to get it
right what's going on when when I
explain it um I I tend to use
terminology like like marinade so it's
kind of like the marinade it's the
marinade we're in right now even and
it's what it feels like is that the
energy so the marinade is basically the
energy that bathes us it's what you're
marinated in and it feels like our
physical reality
um seems to really
um I use this word Loosely thrive on
fear-based energy but it's not thriving
we're all in survival mode and so every
decision we make comes from a place of
fear
and we can say it comes from a place of
survival because survival comes from
fear of death you're doing everything
you can to avoid death so every decision
we make and and it's the same right now
and you know the way that our our
marriage our culture our world our
marinade is set up even right now it's
based on fear fear of failing fear of
dying fear of disease fear of illness
but when I left my physical body and I
entered this whole other realm I was in
a completely different marinade so it
literally is like being pulled from one
marinade into and being bathed by
another and this other marinade was
completely love it was I was just bathed
in this feeling of just unconditional
love and
I sometimes feel the word unconditional
is redundant because if love is
conditional then it's not love
um but yet on this physical Planet a lot
of times love does feel conditional we
feel that we have to we have to earn it
we have to work hard at maintaining it
but what I realize that if it's really
love
it's it is unconditional if it's not
unconditional then it's not love it's
something else
um so basically I didn't have to do
anything to prove myself I didn't have
to do anything to maintain that level of
love I was loved just because I existed
and that's when I realized
um just from the contrast of being from
one marinade to another I realized oh my
gosh this is how I should have been
living life with the Assumption or the
knowledge that I am loved
unconditionally I didn't have to make
all my choices and decisions from Fear I
could have made them from a place of
love so in other words instead of a fear
of failing and making choices of what do
I want to do with my life so that I
don't fail it was more like it should
have been more like what do I love to do
what do I want to do with my life
because this will enhance it this will
make my life even more joyful or
beautiful
um and even things like to do with our
bodies here we are marinated in a
feeling of our bodies are like walking
time bombs that we could get sick we
could be the next one to get cancer or
the next one to get covered so what do I
have to do to prevent it oh let me get
all these supplements or let me go for
um all these let me do all these
self-checks and so our body becomes
something we fear but I realized on the
other side
that our bodies are actually amazing and
powerful and miraculous more than we've
ever been led to believe and we don't
and we're not supposed to fear our
bodies we're supposed to love our bodies
and see them for the Miracles they are
and not focus on Illness but in fact
focus on how well it functions and how
it heals from even the smallest thing or
the biggest things so it was just the
contrast
and marinade is just the best word I can
come up with
yeah could it could it be replaced with
something like reality or Dimension or
something like that marinade does give a
nice visual
um but are those kind of exchangeable
words
yes yes they they are so it was so
basically I did enter into another
reality another realm but the
interesting feeling was that the purpose
of life was to live that way over here
and to not buy into this illusion of
fear that was the biggest message I got
it's like like wow I never loved myself
I never knew I was so loved I always
lived in fear I didn't know how powerful
I was so I realized that that our
purpose here is to break through this
illusion of fear and to realize the
truth of who we really are and that's
and and so the trick was to bring that
Dimension into this Dimension and that's
been the challenge of course of course
how long were you in this experience
not that long like 30 36 hours like not
more than a day and a half well you
would feel that way for that long
yeah but yeah
yeah
I was in a coma and I was like literally
out of my physical body but
interestingly after coming back it feels
like I was in there a lot longer like a
lot longer it was like time was
compressed
um everything I experienced there would
have taken me years to experience here
so so that was what was interesting it
felt so much longer after I came back
it's like oh is that only about 30 36
hours uh it felt like a long time wow
I'm I'm curious because
you telling the story right now reminds
me of an experience I had with a lot of
the same information but I didn't it
wasn't a near death it was just what I
would have called a like a
transcendental experience where I just
all of a sudden had this moment I'm not
going to go into a long diatribe about
it because I have told the story before
a few times on my show but basically
this dog was sort of a conduit and I I
sat down on the beach and all of a
sudden it popped up next to me and boom
I was like transported to this energy
that was like an energy shaft it sort of
was like a lightness and the information
in this experience was no matter how far
you go no matter how long you've been
gone no matter what you've done you're
always loved and that there was never a
need for forgiveness because there's not
a judgment in the first place yes you
got it yeah and I was like I mean I
sobbed for like 45 minutes after that
just like in this
awareness that I could never un unfeel
or unknow that there's another reality
that is and another and there's an
energy out there that is pure love so
the point where you don't even have to
forgive anyone because you never judged
them in the first place
and so I but I didn't get the same
takeaway that you did like I didn't come
away with it thinking wow I'm I'm I'm
now I need to orient in my my life in a
different way it was just some an
experience so I'm I'm just curious like
obviously 36 hours is a pretty long time
but what were the actual actions that
you did and the things that you changed
afterwards because
I don't think it changed much at all I
mean the awareness is a shift in my
reality and I I do believe that on an
energetic level I like what would call
like jumped timelines and kind of
entered a new a new timeline reality but
my external world didn't reflect my
internal world yet and so that was a
process which ended up being my last
full-time year as a race car driver and
a relationship ending and all kinds of
things so what was it that what was it
that you did like to to shift everything
in such a short amount of time I mean
truly your story of being able to
eradicate cancer
energetically is literally like the
future I'm super excited that you had
you had the experience that you did
because you're one of the very few
people that has actually said to me that
you had an experience where you
understood you don't have to forgive
people you're one of the very few people
that has said that because I find
usually I have to really explain that
that there is nothing to forgive
um because there is no judgment because
the love is unconditional
um so when I came back
um you know that I I actually think that
you've changed more radically than you
think because it literally is just such
a shift in thinking that it's almost
unconscious that your actions are
different than they would have been had
you not had this experience yeah so so
it's not just a different feeling so so
some of the things that I can tell you
that happened
the first thing was that uh just before
I came out of the experience
um I was given a choice as to whether I
want to come back or not so at first I
didn't want to come back because it was
so amazing on the other side you know
and and my body was sick and dying and I
was suffering and my family was
suffering and I thought why would I want
to come back into this body but that was
when I got the message that now that you
know the truth of who you really are
your body will heal very very quickly
and it was that understanding it was
literally the understanding that the
only reason I had cancer was because I
had never loved myself enough I'd never
believed other people loved me I'd
always lived from this place of fear I'd
always repressed who I am I'd always
denied my own energy I I've always put
myself lost I'd been a doormat a people
pleaser so literally
literally the cancer is my own energy
trying to express itself whereas my
conscious self my physical self is
repressing it and so when I understood
that it was like oh wow all I had to do
was let myself Express itself what does
it mean for myself to express itself it
means allowing my soul the soul who who
just who chose to Incarnate in this in
this time and space through this body
allowing that soul to be all that it
intended to be and that's what I had
repressed I had prevented that soul from
being all that it came here to be and so
when I understood that and came back
with the commitment to myself that I
will never forsake myself again meaning
I'll never forsake my soul I'll always
let my soul Express itself authentically
through this body once I started to make
that commitment my body just started to
heal
um so the changes that came so so one of
the things that I realized also is that
we are all connected energetically we're
all connected and together all of our
energies together is what I call God so
basically God is the all that is it's
the energy of all of us it's of
everything so that means each and every
one of us is an expression of God so if
I deny my own expression if I deny my
soul from expressing itself through me
I'm actually denying God I'm denying God
from expressing itself through me I am
denying even if we want to go a little
bit religious I'm denying God's will but
um so so who am I to deny God from
expressing itself through me expressing
herself through me so when I realize
that we are all an expression of God
um that's when just things changed for
me and I couldn't live the way that I
lived before because
when I would hear so everything changed
the way I perceived the world changed oh
everybody's an expression of God but at
the same time I am as well so I so on
the one hand it's one thing to be able
to see God in everybody else but a lot
of people who are um Who Who Are
Spiritual and who are able to see God in
everyone else they're not always able to
see God in themselves and they
and and they allow themselves to be
walked all over by other people and
that's kind of how I was before the
near-death experience so one of the
biggest Behavior changes for me is that
prior to the near-death experience
um I was brought up to be spiritual or
religious and spiritual I was brought up
a Hindu and I was brought up to believe
to actually see
um to serve other people to help other
people which is all great they're all
great traits and to see God in other
people all great traits but I never saw
God in myself and that was the biggest
shift for me because I would always put
everybody ahead of me even if I was
depleted so even when I had cancer even
when I was at the final stages of cancer
I didn't learn my lessons from the
illness I didn't learn my lessons from
having cancer because even at that point
I worried more about the people who were
taking care of me than I was about
myself I didn't want people to go out of
their way to help me I would worry more
about making them tired than I was about
my own illness it was always about them
it was always about them it was it was
not the illness that helped me to
realize that I also have God expressing
herself through me it was death that
made me realize that it was death that
taught me to see God in my own eyes and
that's really the biggest thing I
learned that healed me let's talk about
fear a little bit I'm I'm curious about
what that fear is telling us like what's
the information when we get scared and
what is a way to alchemize that and turn
that into self-love how do we reframe it
the fear is telling you what you don't
want and and so the question we have to
ask ourselves is if the fear is telling
me what I don't want then what is it
that I do want and that's what we need
to focus on and we need to love and
value ourselves enough to actually
attract what we do want and to actually
set our focus on what we do on and to
align ourselves with what we do want and
a lot of people say things like um oh
you know I try everything to attract
what I want it doesn't come to me the
key is though do you feel that you are
deserving and worthy of it that's the
for me that's the secret sauce it's
always the only work we need to do is to
really
um take remove the blocks that prevent
us from feeling that we are worthy and
deserving of unconditional love that's
really all there is it's as simple as
that it's that all all of us are loved
unconditionally there's no question
about it every single one of us is loved
unconditionally I just wish everybody
knew that and so our only work is to
remove the blocks that prevent us from
knowing that yeah because perception is
reality and you're a perfect example of
that your perception when it was one
versus the other had
Monumental differences in your reality
but your perception had to change so my
favorite quote is by Henry Ford and it's
whether you think you can or you think
you can't you're right you're right so
what is it that's actually operating
this experience for us that's a big
question that's a really big question
when you say what is it that's operating
this experience do you mean what is
behind us what is behind our eyes or
what is in the other realm I'd love to
understand like what is the true nature
of reality like are there universal laws
are there what is it that drives our
reality there's now proof that inanimate
objects don't exist unless observed like
non-localism it's these things are
coming through so when
I feel like when I understand what's
really happening and what creates our
reality
I will know how to play the game better
and I will know how to live a more
joyful life more more fulfilling more
peaceful
uh expansive life and so I'm curious if
you were given any information about
universal laws or what it is that's
actually creating our reality
the way it felt for me it truly was
um
exactly that exactly as the quote you
just quoted it's exactly like what you
believe will be your truth and it's as
simple as that that if um you know
whether you believe something is true or
not it's it that's what you're going to
manifest what it felt like for me was
that everything that I had been taught
about life
was the opposite of how life should
actually be lived and so that means that
even what I had been taught about rules
and laws and I'm talking even about
Universal truths and rules and laws
everything that I had been taught but
every versus everything that I
experienced when I was actually in the
other realm was totally opposite and the
first thing I I started to wonder is why
aren't we taught this I mean surely
there are other people that have
experienced what I'm experiencing it and
I realized and and actually what I
wanted to know is why didn't I know this
when I was born and what came to me was
that I did know this when I was you did
I did know it but it was conditioned out
of me so
so one of the things that I realized
when I was on the other side a what I
would call one of I like to call it a
universal truth but usually when I speak
about it I tell people it's my truth
because sometimes people don't like to
hear that that you're espousing a truth
for everybody so I tend to say this is
my truth and it works for me
um and so one of them is that that you
really really do have to
um love and value yourself first above
and before anyone else and this is a
tough one for many people especially
people who are empaths and this was a
really hard one for me but it's
interesting because if you are somebody
who is an empath if you are somebody who
does feel sensitive towards other people
and you feel sensitive towards the
planet and you want to go out there and
be in the front lines and help people
um
you tend to be the kind of person that
puts yourself last and that was me and
that was exactly me but that is what led
to my downfall that is what led to me
being sick that's what led to the cancer
so
so one thing that I discovered that was
really a truth is that you really do if
you want to make a difference in the
world because we are all connected we
are all energy first we are Spirit first
physical second and the the so the other
universal truth is that uh is that we
are actually Spirit first so the more
expanded
um and the more fulfilled your energy is
the more that your physical body can can
Thrive and live happier healthier and
fulfill its purpose here on Earth and
the more you can uplift other people so
that was the other second universal
truth which is still tied to the first
one
in that because I always
um believed that I had to help other
people first I didn't realize that if I
didn't help myself
I wasn't uplifting other people because
my energy is connected to everybody else
in other words if if we are all
connected and my energy is high I'm
automatically lifting the hole Yeah and
since we're all connected if I am a
doormat if I'm downtrodden if I'm
depleted and I'm on the verge of getting
sick I'm bringing down the whole
so that was the that was the biggest
universal truth I learned that your
energy matters not only mine but
everyone else too yes so
yes the collective so basically
if I can rephrase the whole thing that
the the most important universal truth I
understood was that my energy matters
because we're all connected and so if my
energy is high I'm uplifting the people
around me and if my energy is depleted
and on the verge of being sick I'm
bringing down the people around me so my
self-love my worth my value my ability
to find joy in my life actually matters
to the whole and that was something that
we're never taught I never knew before I
was taught the opposite that I had to
give and give of myself and almost be a
martyr and what I didn't realize is that
by doing that and depleting myself I'm
actually Bringing Down the whole because
there's such a difference between
thinking something and feeling something
can you articulate that difference I I I
mean in my own experience even actually
like if I reflect back on that story
with that dog and my experience in on
the beach was that like something simple
when I wanted to see the dog I couldn't
it wouldn't show up and then as soon as
I let go but not mentally let go of
course that's part of it but when I
physically like emotionally in my body
let go of it and I was like it's fine
all of a sudden the dog would appear it
was like magic obviously I got a lot of
information on this trip but like that
that was that was an example of Letting
Go and and feeling it and so I've also
done manifested manifesting techniques
and meditations where you go into what
is what it is that you want you think
about why but then you also embody the
elevated emotions having accomplished or
done it
um and and truly it's magical when you
do it things happen things can happen so
quickly sometimes they don't but but it
can and so there's just a difference
between the actual feeling and I I kind
of think this is what works with people
too is there's such a disconnect between
what comes out of someone's mouth and
how they actually feel and that's why a
song or a message or something can just
like hit home versus
sort of roll off of you is because
there's a frequency with truth that's
happening so like why is that what's
going on that we have to like we have to
actually feel it what what is what's
happening why is that the magic sauce
that is the magic sauce so there's a big
difference between thinking something
and feeling something a huge difference
um so we can stuff our brains with
information but it won't really have an
effect I mean it's like going to school
you go to school and you fill your
brains with all this information but
it's not going to have an impact in the
world until something pulls at your
heart so the way I describe it in the
language I use is the heart is the
connection to your soul your heart tells
you why your soul came here what it
wanted to express and but your head is
so your heart is connected to you to the
other realm to your soul your head is
connected to this Physical Realm your
head is where you need to store the
tools to help you navigate on how to get
from A to B but your heart is the one
with the vision because your soul came
here with an intention of something to
fulfill and your soul kind of already
knows the intention that it came with
even though you always have free will
you have the free will to follow your
purpose or not or to follow your Soul's
Calling or not
um I like to use the term calling
because it's almost like your future
self calling you towards it yeah and yet
we always have the choice as to whether
to follow that or not
um and so when you know that when you're
when you're listening to your heart when
you get the when you get chills or when
you get those aha moments so you could
be listening to a podcast or something
and it's just going in your head and
it's just going in your head but the
minute you get that oh and you and you
want to rewind that bit and you want to
play it again because it just it it gave
you an aha moment something dropped like
when you say the penny dropped for me it
means it dropped from your head to your
heart now you feel it once you feel it
you can't unfeel it it means it's there
it's embedded in your body to me
you have to look out for those aha
moments and what those aha moments are
telling you it's your Soul's way of
communicating with you so it's your
Soul's way of saying that that that is
part of your mission that so so whenever
you feel that aha or you feel the chills
or you feel and I know that anybody
listening would know what I'm talking
about it's like you can be listening to
something and something Suddenly It's
like whoa I get that
um so that is your Soul's way of
communicating with you I also love the
sort of more proactive side of it which
is calling it in like you said it's
calling to the Future and so when you
can let yourself go there which includes
things like needing self-love self-worth
because you have to actually believe you
deserve it to be able to generate the
feeling like you have to kind of that's
I because that ends up being one of the
hardest parts is like truly viscerally
embodying the feeling of gratitude or
seeing what you want or having what you
want
um excitement gratitude any of those
things are hard to access because like
cognitively or Pro or whatever get got
programmed as in childhood says you
don't deserve that you shouldn't have
that you're not worthy of that
um and and so it like serves as like
these like this maze to get through so
that you can embody that feeling because
it's just it's such a powerful tool you
had mentioned
um talking about sort of lives and you
know what she came here for and like
what about con Soul contracts
reincarnation how much of life is Free
Will versus determinism interestingly in
the other realm time doesn't feel linear
and it feels compressed so I was aware
of I I was aware of certain
um what I would just call Milestones
like I didn't I didn't see my entire
future unfold before me because we
always have free will to go on a
different path or to not follow what our
Soul's Calling is so
so what I believe is that we come here
with the intention to fulfill certain
things and and that's what it is it's an
intention we come here with that
intention that oh I'm going to go into
the world and I'm going to change this
and I'm going to and I um and then we
make we do make contracts and agreements
with other people in
um other Souls like I know that my my
husband and I we are absolutely
connected in in every way we do have a
soul contract because I truly knew that
when I was in that realm that if I chose
to stay there and not come back he would
not be able to fulfill his his purpose
or his in his Soul's intentions either
that they were completely connected and
when I came back and told him this he
said oh absolutely he said that he he he
said he has always known that his
um purpose in this life
he's known that it's a bigger purpose
but yet he's also known that his purpose
and and this is going to sound
interesting but that his purpose was to
protect and support me through my
journey and and so he actually felt that
part of his purpose was to even see me
through that experience of death and and
help me to come out of it because he was
there holding my hand and willing me to
come back so when I was not yet in a
coma and I would say but I'm dying you
know I'm I'm you know I was like saying
that but what if I do die and he would
say you're not gonna die because I'm I'm
gonna come and get you he truly believed
that his contract was to make sure that
I didn't die at that point that I would
be taken to the brink of death and
brought back and the truth is when I was
on the other side the realization that
our contract was linked and that if I
died he would follow soon after was a
big part of what brought me back so you
saw that on the other side this isn't
like I'm curious about the difference
between his conviction
assisting you versus their actually
being the truth of the contract on the
other side so you were able to witness
that you had an awareness to that I had
a complete awareness of my soul contract
in fact with each member of my family
you know I saw I saw my brother who was
older than me in this physical life I
saw him and me and him in another life
where
um where he was much younger than me and
I was a much older sister and I was
almost his caretaker and and so while I
was there in that nde state or out out
of my body I was I was also able to see
that right this moment while my physical
body was dying my brother was
frantically trying to get on a plane to
reach me before I died because he was
getting so first even before he got the
news that these were my final hours
he felt something he actually felt
something was going on he just suddenly
he told me this later he got up in the
middle of the night and thought what am
I doing here my sister is in the
hospital I need to get there and then as
he's driving to the airport he gets the
phone call from my husband saying you
better come she's in her final hours but
he's already taken the action to do that
and while I'm in the coma I nobody told
me he was coming I saw him on the plane
coming and I thought oh I better not die
before he gets here that would devastate
him what happens if we break these
contracts did you did you get any
information on that
you know in a way I did like it wasn't
so in that moment it wasn't even a
decision of I better not die at all it
was more like I better not die before he
gets here when I saw the contract I had
it with my husband if I did break the
contract and still choose to cross over
something would happen like in whatever
in six months or a year or whatever that
would cause him to cross over and it
would be fine so in a in a way it would
be fine and that we would still be
together we would probably make another
contract to try something again another
time but
um it still felt like but we did choose
this this time so maybe we should go
through with it so so you you still
always have the choice to go either way
but here's the interesting thing from
that realm nothing feels really bad
nothing like nothing feels because
you're already in death so nothing feels
life and left like it does from this
perspective it feels much more drastic
here than it does there it's like oh
it's still gonna be okay from that realm
it always feels everything's going to be
okay but yet when we say it here it
sounds really glib and almost uncaring
when someone's going through real
heartache and grief and pain and when
you tell them everything's going to be
okay they're like no but it's not so
over here we have to honor the pain that
people are feeling but from that
perspective
it really does feel like you know time
is compressed so we're going to be
together in no time
um and so even other lifetimes they're
all compressed so it's like you have
access to all of them
um but yet you can tell that yes this
one is way before this one but the other
interesting thing that I learned which I
did not know in physical life I had
always thought that lifetimes play
um a you know like you think linear and
you think that of course I take the
lessons I learned in this lifetime to
the next one and Karma plays out and if
I did this bad thing in this life I have
to repay it in that life it doesn't work
that way on that side Karma doesn't
exist from One Life to another karma is
something like over here it's like you
know we use expressions like karma's a
[ __ ] and and we kind of say that what
goes around comes around it does within
this life lifetime
um you know I mean kind of like you you
you reap what you sow is what I'm saying
that's all it is it's you reap what you
sow but when you're in that realm and
you're looking at your lifetimes it's
like when you're in this state of being
there between lives you completely erase
all the Karma I know this completely
went against everything I was brought up
to believe and so I still get a lot of
pushback for that from my own uh like
say from the Indian Community from the
Hindu Community uh people have a lot of
trouble wrapping their mind around it
but just like when you cross over and
you realize there's nothing to forgive
even though while you're here
people do feel that that oh this person
really really hurt me and it would be
hard to move on before I forgive them
for it and so on but on the other side
you you totally get why they did what
they did it's the same with with even
Karma it's like oh I wouldn't have done
that if I knew this or oh I was set up
you know like the life I was living led
me to doing this the karma gets
completely erased and then you kind of
work on what's the next experience you
want to have and it doesn't mean that if
you were a criminal in this life that
that you're going to
that you're going to have an awful life
next life you may actually even get to
experience the complete opposite and
realize wow this is what it's like to
have a blessed life that's you know I
don't need to be a criminal you believe
in reincarnation
I do we believe absolutely that we have
multiple lives yes we do and we get to
experience different things okay so
what's the point of reincarnation I
always want was under the impression it
was all about sort of your Soul's
Evolution and growth and that you had to
end up sort of making your way through
life's lessons
um to achieve a certain sort of
frequency to not have to come back to
this reality
which is a lot of Duality and suffering
and pain so although that is somewhat
true as a whole
as a whole we are evolving as the idea
is to evolve all of us as a whole
you know and so if you think about it
like you could even have somebody who is
so involved to even actually choose to
come back
as a criminal
to give the planet an opportunity
to
um for example as an example to even
change a system a change a system of
justice or change the criminal system
somebody could actually be so evolved
it's like I know this is an illusion I
know that I'm going to be fine so I'm
going to allow myself to actually take
the fall for something go to jail be a
criminal be beat not you know they could
actually choose to do that from an
evolved space and you don't always know
what the person's actual trajectory is
it's only on the other side where all of
it is kind of known and so this these
are some of the things that I have had
to wrap my head around after coming back
it's like wow um Karma and reincarnation
isn't the way I thought and the way that
we are taught to believe is linear it's
like I do this and then I have to evolve
more in my next life and evolve more my
next life no you could be super involved
and say I'm gonna go here and be this to
give people an opportunity to work or to
evolve something that needs to be
evolved wow wow so can you choose to not
reincarnate yes you can actually you can
choose to not reincarnate what else
could you be are you ever I don't know
if you believe in extraterrestrials or
other other beings in the universe or is
it just a source Consciousness like what
else could you be if you didn't want to
be a human I do believe that we can be
other forms of Consciousness and exist
on other planes
um and those other planes could even be
other planets that could be existing as
on other planets beyond the Galaxy I do
believe there's a lot out there that
still that we don't know yet for sure I
do believe that when we have that we
have what we call UFOs or
extraterrestrials and spottings of
extraterrestrial beings it's actually
possibly even our future Consciousness
traveling back to try and help us from
what we're going through right now or it
could even be more more evolved versions
of ourselves coming to help us and we
are heading towards that future because
um you know if we're touching on
extraterrestrials
if extraterrestrials I mean they are so
Advanced if they can come on come here
uh in the craft that they come here I
actually believe if they are that
advanced if
um if they if they wanted to they could
have annihilated us but the fact that
they haven't means that they're actually
trying to um help us and Advance us
that's what I believe
what do you do you believe that there's
any sort of extraterrestrial meddling
with something like I mean if we just
even we've been talking about fear and
um how that is sort of the antithesis of
what we're supposed to be feeling for
ourselves
um like covet was a giant giant giant
experience in testing people's limits of
fear so
what is that why why did that what is
the
truth about that
um and again this is my perspective it
feels almost like we are living in two
realities here in the physical and I'm
not talking about the reality of the
other realm if we count the other round
then that's three realities so I often
feel that I have not one foot on each
side but a foot on three sides so so
what do I mean by that so okay so we
have the other realm which is our soul
and um you know and for me it's the
other realm is also
um other beings my my deceased loved
ones and I do feel guided all the time I
feel I'm communicated they're
communicating with me and guiding me all
the time and they're trying to
communicate and when I say they I'm
talking about either our higher self our
soul our guides our deceased loved ones
they try to communicate and guide us all
the time but we have to be open to it so
that's one reality then here in the
physical
I've I feel that we have almost become
like two worlds there is the world that
is living in fear and then there is the
world that can see through the fear
those are the two worlds that are here
so I choose not like heaven and hell
could you call that heaven and hell yes
you you pretty much could so Heaven and
Hell exist right here on Earth it's not
in the afterlife it's right here on
Earth
um and the afterlife is I just call it
pure love pure Consciousness but Heaven
and Hell Is Right here and hence the
title of one of my books is what if it
what if this was Heaven in other words
you can choose to live in heaven right
here so Heaven is seeing through the
fear hell is living in the fear the
people that live in the fear they live
in the fear because there is a fear of
things like a fear of scarcity they live
in in a world of scarcity a world of
competition there isn't enough to go
around so I have to get ahead of
everybody else they live in a world of
um where we are victims we're victims of
our reality victims of illness the thing
is even illness it doesn't happen in a
vacuum it happens because of the seeds
you sow and you can reverse it so but
we're not taught all that the the way
that the medical model is designed it's
designed to make us feel that we are
victims of our illness and we're
helpless to them so
um so covid really really
um really pounded that that
um that in us a lot so um and edu the
education system as well you know it's
about it's about
um getting ahead of everyone else in
your class so when you see through the
fear you realize that there is more than
enough to go around but you just have to
be able to see through the fear to to be
able to access it when you see through
the fear you realize that collaboration
works better than competition it gets
all of us ahead faster but unfortunately
the fear is so entrenched in some people
that the more you have people that see
through the fear
the more fearful
the fear-based people become so the more
they push their fear-based agenda and
hold on to it tighter and that's what I
see happening in the world today but I
choose to align myself with the people
who see through the fear yeah yeah it's
it's my own experiences have shown me
how things aren't just separate they're
part of the same whole so it's kind of
like almost like a teeter-totter where
it's like we're all part of the same
hole and the more people you know like
have you know are elevating and going oh
this is you know the see I see through
the fear it sinks the other side and
it's sort of like you know it's a could
be a teeter-totter it could be just um
uh expanding bubble of polarity that's
really actually
continuous and and and connected yes but
it does feel like there's just this sort
of expanding and Contracting of emotions
and experiences and there's one on each
side because it we live in a time where
you could say like oh my there's so many
perspectives that you could have that
are like oh everything is so bad there's
so much corruption there's so much this
but then you can also look on the other
side and go like we can have this
conversation and people understand like
uh we can there is so many more people
that are seeing through things we're
seeing the truth which is always going
to set you more free and so there's a
lot of actual like extremely Progressive
and enlightening and wonderful things
happening but there's also the other
side of it
um
I wonder uh like as we're talking about
sort of determinism and Free Will and
soul contracts what about
prayer and what about the power of it
and whether or not we can alter
timelines or Futures based on that
yes absolutely so it's both prayer and
meditation and group prayer and
meditation is very powerful to me so I
tend to organize a lot of group
meditation I do that to uplift the
planet to so it starts with uplifting
yourself because again if you're not
uplifted the people around you are going
to feel it so group energy so whether we
call it prayer whether we call it
meditation we are essentially doing the
same thing we are sending out positive
vibes and positive intentions to the
world we're expanding our own energy so
this is actually what's happening
whether it's prayer or meditation you're
actually expanding your energy and
you're sending it out into the world so
when people come together and do this um
I'm going to say when people come
together in the same time and space it's
super powerful but although time and
space is really compressed looking at it
from the other realm but yet I still
feel the energy of it when I bring a
group of people together when I actually
I either do it sometimes online or I do
it physically I put a shout out and I
say hey I'm going to be here who wants
to join me for a group meditation to
uplift the planet and the meditations
that I do tend to start with let's all
start with expanding our own energy
let's all see see ourselves as being
full and whole and healed and loved and
so we start with that so we feel good
about ourselves and then we expand it
outward
um I really feel that if more and more
people if more kids learn to do it if it
was part of their morning ritual when
they get to school with the whole school
does it as a morning you know a morning
prayer or morning meditation I think we
could change the whole planet I really
do yeah I mean we used to go to school
when I was a kid and I'm pretty sure
they don't do this anywhere now but we
used to say the national anthem
you'd stand up next year stand up next
to your desk put your hand on your heart
I pledge allegiance to the flag like you
know I mean that used to be so why
wouldn't you just have everyone stand up
and just sort of
visualize their field expanding and
strengthening and becoming more positive
I mean there's so many things I mean
what's the reframe what's the reframe or
the restructuring for
the
fastest progression of our planet if you
were to call the shots on what some I
don't know top three top five changes
that would be the most influential to
shifting our planet into a new
frequency State of Consciousness what
would you do
so if it were up to me I would want
everybody to to change their value so
for example right now if you look around
the world Cutting Edge technology
invention every form of progression
every former the way we're evolving the
number one value that it's based on is
money it's based on money that that is
behind everything
um like if you think about medicine if
you think about health care the bigger
factor is the money and not the
individual person's health if you think
about education teachers aren't getting
paid as much as they should considering
they're molding young people's lives
like the biggest Factor behind every
single evolution in in this in our
current modern world is money the
biggest driving Factor so let me put it
that way the biggest driving factor is
money if we shifted that and if we made
well-being the well-being of humanity
the biggest driving Factor behind
everything we do our reality would
change just like that
just like that because that was the
biggest shift I made in my life was that
I made my personal well-being the
biggest value of my life so everything
that I did everything that I
um moved forward doing it wasn't about
does it bring me more money does it uh
does it you know is this a good career
move none of those decisions mattered it
was like what does it do for my
well-being and once I made that shift my
life just changed moving forward and I
believe that if everything that Humanity
did was based on the well-being of the
people then it would change dramatically
and if I can just expand on that just a
little bit that we have Cutting Edge
technology that exists but it's not
public knowledge it's not even
cutting-edge technology for healing for
healing cancers but it's not being
approved by governments to be used
because even though this is technology
that exists it's been done by scientists
it's been researched but it's not being
approved because it will
um it will actually cause the current
Paradigm the big money-making machine of
pharmaceuticals and the current research
and the current technology it would
cause that Paradigm to lose money and so
new technology is not released at the
pace at which it's being developed it's
being released at the pace at which the
people who make the money are willing to
relinquish yeah or at the pace in which
they can find a way to monetize it
exactly yes so it's being least at the
pace I like that that's a much better
way of phrasing it it's being released
at the pace at which people can find a
way to monetize it but if we put
well-being ahead of money
it would be a very different reality a
very different
um yeah very different line of evolution
and we would be so far ahead like so
basically people's
minds and technology and resources would
be used far more for helping people
healing people helping the planet as
opposed to creating nuclear weapons we
spend far more on nuclear weapons than
we do on helping people and feeding
people I love those like gifts or
whatever they are where it shows like
aliens on another planet it's like oh
should we go down there and they're like
no they're still making weapons to blow
themselves up like what's going on like
I mean it's just so ridiculous
um I mean it's true I I I the money side
of things what have you ever heard about
sort of like a
3D 5D shift Like A New Earth is the new
Earth concept something you've heard of
and if you have what is that
um so I believe that we are heading that
way uh it's inevitable so it's only one
of two scenarios either we make
ourselves extinct or we head that way
but I'm optimistic extremely optimistic
that we are heading into a new and
better reality
um but I also feel that those that are
holding on to the older reality
um are going to be holding on tighter
and won't let it go into the new reality
without Kicking and Screaming but I feel
that whatever forces that are out there
our own our own people our own deceased
relatives or whether it's the
um extraterrestrials whatever forces are
out there are actually helping us so I'm
very very optimistic about moving into
this new reality this new dimension
we'll just kind of finish up here by
talking about sensitivity since that's
your latest book is sensitive as the new
strong
um and what does that mean what does it
mean to be sensitive and how does that
help us moving forward
so one of the things that I've noticed
is that
um
we have been uh brought up to believe
it's kind of ingrained in us that
sensitivity is a negative thing and that
if you're sensitive you're going to come
last and that you're not going to do
well in the world you're not going to
survive you're not going to succeed and
if you look at it logically this kind of
explains why you know like by by
actually conditioning people by
ingraining these beliefs in us
um we are actually creating a world
where the most insensitive people are
the ones that are going to get ahead and
become world leaders where actually
um seeing sensitivity empathy as
weaknesses as traits that people don't
want so those who are sensitive are
going to hide it so what are we doing
here we've created a world where being
we're using Brute Force
um where being Brash where being
um being a bully being narcissistic all
these things are the trade that actually
get you ahead and then we kind of wonder
how why is the world the way it is of
course it is if that's what we're going
to teach our kids and we do that by like
if you have especially young males if if
a boy is sensitive we tend to say grow a
thick of skin Boys Don't Cry
um and so and so that's why if we notice
that quite often in many organizations
and in government roles in politics most
of the people I won't say all but most
of the people that actually make it to
the top are usually the the ones that
are the least sensitive to the needs of
other people so I believe that if we
want to change our Paradigm if we do
want to enter this Fifth Dimension we
really need to change the parameters of
what it means to be strong and
sensitivity needs to actually be seen as
a strength if we want leaders who are
sensitive to other people's needs if we
want leaders if we want this new world
where we start changing our values where
it becomes where people's well
well-being is far more valuable than
money where cutting-edge technology
we're helping people is far more
valuable than developing more nuclear
weapons than we do need to see
sensitivity as a strength and that's
what I advocate for that sensitivity
needs to be valued and nourished and
encouraged and seen as a strength and we
need to vote in more sensitive people
into Power I come from a unique position
where I I feel my orientation with
people is awareness like I am aware of
how you feel but I don't have I don't
take on your feelings so I don't have
that sort of I don't have that aspect of
empathy I can if I've had the direct
experience so I'm a pretty pretty big
firsthand learner so once I've had the
experience I know now when someone is in
a situation I can empathize more much
more easily and fluidly but if I haven't
had it I don't necessarily feel your
feeling although I'm aware so for anyone
out there that feels like me what is the
high road of people people that are not
necessarily Su so sensitive but have
will have power have strength like how
is that best used and channeled to
um on their own or working with
sensitive like how how can the Two
Worlds sort of join and I almost feel
like this is like paralleling sort of
the masculine and feminine that's
happening in the world where not only
within each other but more than more
than that is actually within each other
like how do we unite this masculine and
feminine so how does the sensitive work
with this the other side the it's not
the strong because that's what you're
trying to say is that sensitive is
strong so how do those sort of energies
unite so there's empaths who actually
feel what other people are feeling even
if they have no experience of it of of
their own then there are the people who
are just sensitive but not empaths like
yourself and my husband Danny is like
like that too
where you are sensitive to the needs of
the other person but you're not taking
it on in your own body
um and and I always say people like you
people like Danny they make the perfect
um like say for example
um healthcare workers because you don't
take on the sickness of the person
whereas an empath actually feels it in
their own body and then but if you go to
the other end of the scale which is the
people who are not even sensitive
they're not even aware of the needs of
the people who have needs so you
actually are in the perfect position to
help the most amount of people because
you don't get burdened by what they're
feeling so people like you have great
minds for actually working
um helping them to work their way out of
that situation you guys make the best um
absolutely super caring
um doctors surgeons Engineers because
your mind can immediately understand
you're sensitive enough to know that oh
this situation calls for this I can help
them create it
um so someone who is an empath is
usually burdened by feeling what they're
feeling and they don't all they're not
always able to to help them create the
solution someone who's on the other end
the not sensitive is not even aware what
they're feeling so you are in the
perfect position to help people create
Solutions and so I tell people I would
tell people like yourself I tell Danny
use that strength you have that
sensitivity as a strength to actually
create solutions for people and use that
voice
um to use your voice to actually share
it so for example one of the things that
Dany is doing now because he was with
with me when I was really really sick
and he saw me going through what was
supposed to be death
and he cared for me he knows what it
feels like to have a partner or a spouse
who is dying and who is really really
sick and yet
he knows and he knows he knew he knew
everything I needed even before I would
ask for it he was able to anticipate it
but if he was an empath he would have
needed breaks from me to recover himself
because he would have been absorbing my
feelings yeah he would have been burned
out but he wasn't he was actually able
to support me all the way through and
now he's using his voice to share with
other people how they can support
um partners and spouses like he's
starting a show a program called in
sickness and in health speaking to other
caregivers because the other thing that
happens is that someone who is in your
position who is sensitive
um people who are like say like I I was
going through the illness the person
going through the illness gets all the
attention but the person who is the
primary caregiver doesn't get any
support or attention they're the ones
that are just doing and doing and doing
so so that's why he's created he's
creating this program for them and uh
yeah so I so that's why I think people
like yourself you can use your voice to
actually
um to to actually beat that drum of
sensitivity is a strength it is a
strength and we can use it as a strength
yeah beautiful just aspects of empathy
and we need we need we need we everybody
is needed it takes as I say all the time
it takes All Kinds of Kinds and if we
were all the same it wouldn't be this
this uh this uh this game or this
experience or this reality wouldn't be
much fun so thank you for sharing your
story for
um I feel like I'm this is me putting
words to and maybe in your mouth or
describing you in a way that I didn't
hear but like really what it feels like
is committing your life's work to
um
to a cause to the cause that the whole
planet needs so thank you and um thank
you for your time and I appreciate all
of these
many gems that you shared with us
thank you so much Danica it was it was
really a pleasure to be here speaking
with you thank you
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today I hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the Subscribe button